[Music]
welcome back
thank you and welcome back they said it
wouldn't last and here we are
deep into that episode number 18
they did say it wouldn't last i was
always down
i never break up with anybody like
people have to dump me i never i
like thank god really no i feel like it
was close
it's freaking no i i knew this show
would only ever end if you
said i can't end anything i've never
ended anything like even the most toxic
relationships where people like cheat on
me over and over
and give me a seat like i still won't
i've never cheated on you or giving you
a nist
thank you we're doing good we're doing
good
um yeah and people are like okay that
we're getting along i thought maybe if
we weren't fighting and have being so
toxic people might not like it as much
but people like we still like it even
when they're
getting i feel like it's better when we
get along it's just yeah it's a lot when
we're
fighting i mean but i'm always down to
fight we were watching your h3 live and
you guys were like [ __ ] on joel
olsen and i literally was talking to
moses like i have to turn this off like
there's
like joel stupid such a dark time how
did he help you
because you know what it is and i hate
people like you for this reason we just
said we love each other and i do love
you but
it's such a douche no because when
people are like
let's say you maybe you've been there
maybe you haven't when you're like so
suicidal and you're just like
life i'm just gonna end it like there's
literally no point to life and you hear
something even if you think it's
[ __ ] if you think it's all like
you know just whatever when you hear
those because i have so many negative
voices in my head when i hear like one
positive thing and you could say it's
[ __ ] whatever
it's just like oh maybe i'm not i don't
think it's [ __ ] but i do think that
there's a lot of people that can provide
that service to people
and so in your case it happened to be
joel but i also think joel is like a
really shady person he's health and
wealth and i like that he preaches that
because my church
i was catholic for so long and they
preach a lot of like suffering and i
didn't like that i like that joel
preaches
all well for him and everyone else gives
that that's how he gets
rich everyone gives him their [ __ ]
money a
i wanted that cube i wanted to go google
it after you guys talked about it i was
like where do i get this
exactly love joel olsen so much like
he's safe right now you want to hand me
the cube so people can see what we're
talking about i love him and i was
pissed when i was watching joel austin
do you remember what he did when houston
was like flooding he literally like
didn't let people people were he didn't
like open up his [ __ ] mega church to
people
your your company your teddy fresh
headquarters for people what for people
in houston
maybe do you know where i live no yeah
i live in l.a get it you know no i don't
anyway once you got dragged
do i have this well it's kind of
important bro i'll buy i'll pay for
double
so on friday we we premiered the
joel austin inspirational queue
here you want to hear daily inspiration
affirmation or sermon
you bought into it well this was bought
on ebay so somebody else made money
dude prosperity gospel is one of the
biggest scams perpetuated on the
american people it helps people it's not
a scam
it's not like okay money don't give them
money you don't have to give money i'd
watch solo team for free
like i've never once yeah and you know
all these these internet marketers
all their content's free until they get
you well don't be stupid
that's it that's just stupid you see
that guy driving around in jets and [ __ ]
like
somebody's giving him a [ __ ] help me i
never gave him a dollar so thank you
i'm glad i'm i'm just saying there's
lots of people so aggressive about it
like you're so like
hatred for him because he takes
advantage of people
of people who are in a really vulnerable
state tell you one other thing the more
you give the more you'll receive i've
given
you i've gotten abundance 10 times what
i've given
give give give and you receive so much
more back no but joel osteen says give
to me
and guess what i bet those people got
rewarded in 10 times in abundance yeah
there's a bunch of bored people in this
[ __ ]
i don't think so i know a lot of they're
all rich people i know a lot of wealthy
people that like we're down there
my family member is included for some
victories we have to prove to god
that we'll do the right thing that says
this
we have to be good to people when
they're not being good to us
we we have to be good to people i don't
trust people that talk like that
when when they have to be good to us
you're such a hater i was like actually
hating you oh and i lost well
he helps a lot of people he helps a lot
you're just so like aggressive just say
like it's not for me
you have to be he's like of like this
he's
he's literally the embodiment of holding
someone up by their legs and
jiggling the change out of them like
this is what he does to his congregation
give me your [ __ ] lunch money kid oh
my god
i'm gonna give him or how do i donate to
joel's scene when it's taking long i'm
sure it's easy
next charity i'm playing for it tell me
how to get my money how bad
do you want what god promised you how
bad do you want it
well god promised you such bitterness
out of somebody like it's here it
literally
takes advantage of vulnerable people
like you know kenneth copeland you
probably love it i don't
know who that is at all he's even better
um but anyways it was good
i endorsed the h3 after dark now oh
thank you so much
maybe not the original h3 like the ones
you guys do like regular like politics i
don't like that but the after dark is
good
thank you so much for whatever interview
where he said i'm not
comparing him to hitler but i know he's
like he's like he goes which
this is mine i said that originally i
was like hitler had a lot of followers
so i feel like that was mine but
honestly so
big nick who was a former vlog squatter
because he's friends with jason so
that's fine yeah
and he said well he said in jason's
defense he was one of the only few guys
that stood up for me so i thought that
was well i mean everyone has different
experiences with different people i'm
sure some people meet dave i'm like oh
my god he's the best person ever the
one's getting teslas from him but it's
like
right i was in dating him it's a little
different
so anyway big nick called in on friday
on our after dark app
and said he goes uh i don't want to make
a big
big bad comparison but hitler had a lot
of followers
i'm not comparing the two i was like
but is he wrong i mean i don't know if
it's the best analogy
jesus christ had 12. and look who rose
and look who's down in hell
thank you i respect my round of applause
here let's get it
let's get an affirmation for that hold
on i need an affirmation for that
praise the lord jesus help me lord
everything
grace you need for today you are full of
power
strength and determination that's great
nothing you face
will be too much for you you will
overcome every obstacle
outlast everything you will overcome
every obstacle
you will [ __ ] every hot [ __ ] you want
you will
you will make a ton of money some people
need to hear that for real because you
will go to joellosteen.com and hit
donate
you don't have any schizophrenic
tendencies but when you hear like i hear
actual voices like
when we were out this weekend i thought
somebody was talking like i was checking
out somewhere
and like what was that and she was i
didn't say anything i heard i literally
heard ten like negative voices in my
head
and so when you start hearing like
actual voices like hearing something
like that from like somebody else that's
not in your head
it's like a positivity you want me to
film some i can make my own
inspirational cue
i'll go you will overcome everything
today
you will you will
go to starbucks and they'll make your
coffee perfect
anyways can i mention one more thing
because i know we're playing a game
stand i just want to mention one more
thing on this podcast while we have this
your team will win the super bowl
can we save this for h3 like this is
did you watch the britney spears
documentary i did it was so good
did you watch it for real yes okay free
britney okay
okay yes free britney but also oh this
is an anti-brittany spiel no no i love
britney oh my god but i i don't blame
jamie all the way and if you're
listening jamie spears like i
would love to just join brittany meaning
like she lives close to us where we
moved
and i would like to be her friend off
social media i'll sign it
oh so you're pl making a play to be
friends with the dad so you can get the
british no i want to be friends with
brittany like let me in you know
why are you defending her dad i don't
think he's
because i want to go into the house yeah
you're just trying to be you just yeah
but but i'm telling him like i'm coming
in as a peace offering i know i have a
pocket like i can
i can talk about do you think he's
watching this what's the chances you
think he's watching i think it'll get
back here brittany
and i'm no but i'm not britney free
brittany i know her struggle like not
the famous part that part was crazy no
you know her struggle well let's try to
get chased
this weekend and actually someone came
around i did there is that but
but i relate to her on such like a deep
do you think we could get brittany on
the pod
i think i could go and maybe get an
exclusive inside the house i don't think
she can come to the set
um i'm willing to do it you're willing
to go do that i want to do it no but
like i want to be her friend like
i think she needs a friend and i feel
like i could be her friend but not even
like be public about it i don't need to
be public i don't need
we can because she loves to post on
instagram but i understand her more than
anyone i understand jamie really well i
understand that whole family so well
so jamie if you're he's like what the
[ __ ] no no like jamie i actually love
you
or are you gonna go as ursula as
yourself i've done a lot of britney
cosplays i used to recreate all of
britney's instagrams like i love
brittany but i'll go as myself and like
we have a similar disorder oh
oh my god wait i don't even know this
she went into a mental hospital
a week after my first mental hospital
stay last year in 2019 well two years
ago now
and i was like we have such like paths
again not to like compare myself to her
because she's a queen and she's like
amazing and like super famous and all
stuff like that but you guys are synced
up in your
how do i say this episode how do i say
it i think she might be
not diagnosing but she might have traits
of borderline too and i'm like you know
what
bpt's making it like this come back
we'll have a whole movement going
it's hard to say though because her dude
this documentary was really good i got
super upset watching it
it's on hulu it's like a new york times
thing called
and it's about the free brittany
movement and this whole conservative
conservatory
yeah conservatorship is is unfucking
believable even today she is still
under the thumb of her dad legally and
it's mind-bendingly
insane like how they they argue that
the conservative ship is for people who
are like can't handle their own affairs
for
usually it's for people who are old but
in her case i guess because she was
mentally unstable
yet she's touring the world she's making
music she's working her ass off
and they're at the same time claiming
she's incapable of
conducting herself yet at the same time
she's out
doing like they said quote they they're
like she's a high
functioning conservatory conservatory
yeah and they're like well what the [ __ ]
does that mean how how can
it's just it's crazy it's it's it's
insane
and her dad is like the psycho like who
was like didn't have any part of her
life and that swooped in when she
first checked in the hospital and put
her in this conservative
conservatory ship and like the judge
somehow granted it
i i'm blown away by the whole time i
think jamie was better than the guy that
she was with that guy right before she
went but she
yeah she asked for a third party she
just wanted a third party to do it
an independent party and the judge for
some reason was like
i will not let her hire this lawyer
because she's incapable of
retaining counsel it's like what right
i think um i think jamie spears doing
the best job he can
i think if i go in there maybe you're
just saying that you don't believe that
you don't believe that you really think
you're you're just saying that so you
can get in to see brittany i think he's
better
than like the people she was surrounding
herself with right like
i was telling moses the other day like
literally last night i was like can you
be my conservator because i kind of want
someone to like
make sure i don't get taken an advantage
yeah but she explicitly said i'm okay to
do this
i just don't want my dad to do it so
maybe i could do it
oh my god that's a high level play i
think i could
honestly at least with the
conservatorship of her of her life of
not her finances so you have to get
jamie's consent she has no that's why
i'm saying jamie i don't think you're
crazy so say i think you're doing a fine
job
jamie's her dad say nice things about
her dad baby get i think you're doing
fine job you raise brittany look how
successful she is like
that was you you're in you know and
you're in
i understand brittany i come from a fan
perspective but also as like a human
being
perspective i would never be like let's
take a picture let's do this you know
what i mean like i have a human
relationship
get a hold of jamie you we live within
10 minutes of her not to sound
trisha's trisha's uh jamie spears i've
always actually respected him
like again this documentary opened up
some things but this is only what
they're showing you can edit anyone to
learn
anything i'm the queen of being edited
to look like you know something i'm not
or i can be edited to look like
something i'm great
oh we should say what we're doing today
yeah you're really just trying to get
okay well you know what if i become
friends with brittany i am not going to
tell you
if i can have an exclusive i'm going to
put it on my channel and not for enemies
dude you have that i mean produce the
segment
come on i'll hire him as an independent
no nope dan dan does not work without
dan would you take a job without my
permission
uh no not with tricia i feel like that
would yeah
crossover sorry no offense tristan wait
we're all in tv
no that's obviously going around he's my
employee but if you're cutting
him out like i would come help you
you're gonna cut me out of the brittany
exclusive
all right let's let's get it exclusive
you're gonna be eating your words
no i think i'm totally i'm sure jamie's
watching this and he's he's dialing
right now
he's trying desperately he says he says
i want this lucrative
position i have over brittany to go to
trisha because she understands her
i don't need money i just want to be the
conservative of her life i just want to
control her life he can control the
finances i just want can i be your
conservator
and then what can you be can you be a
conservator if you're a conservative
no i don't think so because i want to
conserve you and you can serve her no
i'm the conservative no don't come for
me okay
i want to say so today we're doing the
newlyweds game even though you guys
aren't technically newlywed
yet but we'll probably get married
before our wedding because for like
legal like legal stuff oh for real
yeah yeah that's fun i don't know i
don't want to say it all i have health
insurance i don't want people to like
speculate
just you don't have health insurance
because he's been like lazy to get it
something he can't have
what the [ __ ] why don't you get health
insurance but he's gonna get it and i'm
like let's just wait till we get married
and put you on my health insurance we
have really good health insurance
anyways what's wrong with you
it was like a weird thing i didn't want
it to like stop there and be like oh he
doesn't have moses you're buying nine
carat diamond rings
you don't have health insurance i mean
what the [ __ ] are you doing with your
life and the young in heaven
i know he has the money to do it health
insurance he's never had it but anyways
it's like
hell so we kind of maybe get married
don't you get tasked for not having it
to the point where it's
like just the same to just get it isn't
that what obama did
he just doesn't probably yeah oh they
were it was just for one year we're
having all these cars together so i'm
like we should probably get insurance
like driver's insurance all on all the
cars of everybody
that's cool get it so anyway anyways
regardless of the technicalities of it
we are doing the newly wed game today
moses and ela is here round of applause
everybody
the spouses are here who happen to be
brother and sister how odd is that
weird yeah that's so odd but there it is
you know we were debating this can you
tell me what you think
ela said i think that trisha and moses
have the advantage because they're like
new love and they're always together
yeah yeah but i said i told you that i
think most people would think me and ela
have the advantage because well we've
just been together for so long i agree
but i was just telling most of that too
because he was kind of like whatever he
didn't know for sure but i was like
we're so intense right now we're in it
so i can remember
where you're born what school you went
to first girlfriend like all that stuff
where i feel like you guys have like
kind of like it's in the past and maybe
not so we're just
we're yeah but we spent our nights being
like
so what's your biggest dream like what's
your you know we have all that so i know
all his i mean
so so it's interesting we we don't know
who exactly has the advantage but i
guess we'll see
yeah i feel like i'm we're definitely
going to lose ethan
you do i don't have that feeling of
you're such a knife so
i think i don't like competitions so i
already just want to think like okay i
lost
and then um yeah and also
i feel like i have mom brain like my
memory is not good
you're busy you're busy you got a lot
going on mom let's say mom brain we're
all busy i mean come on i'm mom brain
too
yeah you never say anything about my
cosplays on air
it's like you just actually i mean look
every day you show up as a new thing i
mean like
yeah no i think you're both it's ursula
bro it's awesome and your hair is
amazing
how does it hold i don't know it's like
device gravity it's like hillary clinton
hair
that is not the look we were going for i
hillary clinton's hair how it just held
and it was big it was just
like a [ __ ] storm trooper helmet and
i prefer to
okay i love that just like crazy that
could stop a bullet
anyway um okay
let's just play i have a few things here
but whatever
you know i just wanted to say before we
get started oh yeah
first of all i wanted to say that i
am so grateful to the frenemies gang
and to you you're so funny and amazing
i never expected this show to become
so i don't say popular but people really
love this show
and you know when i when we made the
show i knew it would be fun and it was
exciting but i didn't
i had no idea that that so many people
would like it
yeah and i just want to say thank you
for
doing the show and i think you are so
funny and talented
and you bring and you just you make the
show so great
oh well thank you for um showing people
that i'm not an evil [ __ ]
you're not an evil [ __ ] yeah literally
no you can be from time to time but i
don't have an evil [ __ ] i think i have
like
episodes yeah that's what i mean it's
like i don't really mean it but i think
you're an evil [ __ ] on like the tip of
the iceberg and then everything else is
like
right very nice wholesome great person
but you know all evil [ __ ] stem from
insecurity any time i've been secure
about something then i'm like oh let's
attack attack attack
of course you know they say they say
jeffrey dahmer for example
ate men because he was trying to fill
just fill the void
that was left by the absence of his
parents are you comparing me to
everything i'm just saying
everything comes from a lack of
something right so
ted bunny was awesome head bonnie very
charming man that was david dobrik it's
charming too
anyway i just want to say thank you to
everybody and thank you to you yes it's
been
uh amazi i mean it's just been amazing
no people i'm public too they come and
i love front of me that makes me so
happy this is like my this is like my
fifth life on youtube like i keep
getting revived like it was shane first
and then dave i feel like
i keep writing these waves so if we ever
have a falling out maybe i'll join the
logang or something
there you go impulsive but it's a
testament to your personality
thank you you know actually the logang
didn't like me i did impulsive and they
didn't like so why do you ride for them
i don't know why do you [ __ ] why do
you insist on defending them
especially when they say i want hackers
and degenerates
to harass ethan and his family people
said that they're like how come
why do you ride for logan and you're
like i was on the show and they were
mean to me i don't understand your
your [ __ ] symptoms checked in with
you first to see if you were actually
affected by it you said you weren't
really that affected by it and second of
all like
i think by what him saying you were this
guy well yeah
i mean how hard am i supposed to take
that i don't know i'm a logang stan
you don't ever turn against jack films
for me so jack's my friend
okay logan he wasn't mean to me like on
his show it's not like i went
it wasn't like i went to his house and
he spit on me and i was like i love him
that's what logan did too all right
let's play the game they were fine okay
the newlywed oh it's valentine's day
that's why it's
yeah did we say that our this episode
was sponsored by adam and eve
oh adam and eve do we need to do it now
before the game
should we do it now oh well we'll cut it
in here adam and eve this episode is
brought to you by adam and eve
here's that adam and eve are we doing it
here at dan no
oh it's not been 30 minutes h3 adam and
eve
hey guys use code h3 adam you have
valentine's day let's do it let's just
[ __ ] do it
let's do it pull it up let's do it
before the game no that'll be an ad
later
let's do it now so we don't have to
interrupt the game adam and eve
tell me about potions and [ __ ] you have
it on your phone yes hey guys
i got it hey guys this episode is
sponsored by adam and eve dot com
you can get anything at adamandeve.com
when you use the code puppy down for 50
off plus free shipping if you're in the
us in canada but here is what the code
hd does that doesn't even get it with my
code or any other code that i've seen
online
it gives you 10 free tantalizing gifts
they give you six toys right off the bat
they give you a gift for him a gift for
her and a gift for you guys to enjoy
damn
but you can only use that with adam and
eve code h3
coach h3 50 off ten free
if you don't use h3 no valentine's day
gifts no free
valentine's day no you literally you're
just you're wasting your
purchase but because it's valentine's
week they're going to give you like
valentine's gifts when you use code h3o
don't get three
items what are they just dumping their
store like they've got like a back where
they're just like no
can i actually tell you i actually know
this because you know some people do
mystery boxes we're not gonna name
anything six free movies
this is actually like priority stuff
that they give you and i've ordered from
them i've used the code to test it out
myself that's a true story i always
test the code out to see what they give
you and give you quality [ __ ] this offer
is insane
it says it says 10 free items that
includes
six movies you think there's fart stuff
in there
i don't know okay just wondering six
movies
a free mystery pack that includes an
item for him a special toy for her and
something we all know
i sent that yeah you did and free
shipping i love it they're really fast
shipping
um they're here in the us so that's why
you get the free shipping in us canada
when you code h3 plus you get 50 off so
god damn that's that's crazy y'all
that's a spice up that sex life
three at abbotteve.com that's h3 and
adam and eve.com
good job trisha you were crushing those
reeds all right let's play the game
all right at long last the newlywed game
that's right okay everyone ready and in
your case
we're the old days yeah it's been
together we got married 10 10
12. so do the math on that okay but how
long have we been together how many
years oh
well we were together for five years
before we got married wow
so we've been together five plus uh 10
10 12
18 now 18 years no
how does that make no it's like a close
12
so that's yeah 14 sounds right
no it's 20 21 and if you guys
we got married in 10 10 we're 10 10 12.
we got married in two yeah
whoa really we got married in 2012. nine
years ago and you said you were together
oh yeah fourteen good job
holy [ __ ] it's wild we've been married
almost ten years coming up oh
that's cool we gotta do something
do you guys do anything for your
anniversary generally not
no but ten years 10 years we should do
something yeah
okay ian how does how should we proceed
or dan what are we doing
uh well i'm going to be reading off the
questions okay let's go
should we put something on the line
what's on the line what's on the line
don't make me donate joel
um i don't know what is a good one the
winner gets
so so here's the thing if i order pizza
you look it's
not that's not does not benefit either
yeah let's do something good
[Music]
we'll think as we play see
i just want food and ela's like dude
maybe the joel olsen cube you can have
the jewel listing cube if you want no
you know what you can't i mean this is
important to me
all right let's just play oh no a heart
fell oh
yeah i feel like dan i mean ian god
bless his soul he just taped it
i just saw that it was just tape
it looks good it looks great i mean we
only need it to last an hour all right
let's play
okay all right so starting off with uh
well what i thought was going to be an
easy one but after hearing that you guys
have been together for 14 years this
might be uh
go ahead all right um ethan this
question is for ethan
and trisha uh-huh what did
your spouse's wear on the first date
that you guys went out on
oh see that yeah that doesn't benefit
crazy i mean i remembered it yeah
i mean i wasn't really generally elo
wait like on first date you said
yeah i'm just writing the first time i
met you either
how about the first time you met the
first time i remember meeting you
really generally that's
dude has been like [ __ ] 14 years what
she wore generally to you when she met
you
i bet we have to i know exactly what ela
were when she met you generally
her israeli uniform nope
does everybody have their answers down
yes all right so ethan wait
no i don't okay did you erase it you're
gonna say that wait wait no you keep
that answer
keep that answer okay we're on question
she told me all right ready
wait no why are you changing it no ethan
and trisha reveal your answers
okay go okay i'll reveal it okay yes
youtube reveal wait ela you better not
change it
i didn't i didn't change you it didn't
change
okay go uh so
white sweater with flowers says tricia
lower it ethan
what is your israeli uniform shirt and
what jeans jeans okay so uh well she was
in her uniform sometimes
eva says soldier outfit give you guys
that yeah yeah trisha actually did give
me
that and then because you weren't always
in your uniform but whatever in the
pictures you guys showed did you guys
get it right but hold on yeah moses
answer is white shirt with flowers
the exact same answer you said yeah okay
whatever i'm not gonna pull
i'm not gonna split hairs after that one
all right so did you
did you guys prepare for this i feel
like you guys
we need to get two points because we got
yours right too
oh interesting interesting this is the
first time
the whole podcast that's the first time
i heard your voice being all right
okay so you guys really did it like that
huh
who is the better kisser in the
relationship
what a funny question so you have to
either put yourself or or the other
tick tock question that's a weird
question this is welcome to the newlywed
game
this is the newlywed this one's so easy
i
don't know come on you know
follow your instincts all right
ethan and trisha reveal your answers me
trish
and ella again ila said herself
and moses trisha okay everybody got it
right
moses like wouldn't kiss me for like
months why i don't know
after you guys had sex yeah we'd have
sex with like we had sex right away
first date but he wouldn't kiss me for
like four months
why wait no we kissed on the first date
well like kiss but not makeup
you like hated making out you don't like
making out moses
well we went there was no time to make
out we were
don't you do that i mean but he did not
like it like on the couch he'd be like
it would be weird he'd be like a stiff
kisser because he didn't like making out
he's like i just never liked kissing i'm
like okay
anyways fascinating fun fact the answer
is fun fact
all right so ethan and trisha if your
partner could delete
one app from your phone what would it be
interesting so wait that's that's i'm
answering you're answering what you
think ila would say
oh that's a great one what she would say
like moses wants to delete an app off my
phone correct
and so you have to guess which one you
think most i mean tinder obviously right
kidding
oh what's the gay one with the gay
dating app uh grinder
grinder grinder
i think i know it it's hard though it's
hard
oh my god okay i'm exposing myself
all right everybody clayton do you have
it i'm really curious with that
that's a hard one you know this too i
hope you guys so
starting starting with ethan and trisha
you two reveal okay twitter
twitter and keeping up with the vlog
squad tumblr
that's so nice that's a nap okay tumblr
so tumblr okay
specifically so yeah let's show ela's
reveal
yeah that was the easy one and well you
were right
and then wait show yours he said vlog
squad i'm gonna give him that
it is it's the vlog squad tumblr i
always follow up oh my god
wait tell me what is what the hell does
that mean yeah what is that
it's like a huge fan that like just
recounts all the vlog squad happenings
that day
you want to follow everything going on
check it it's always about like jason
and david and he's always like
why do you look at that and he'll use to
catch me now i'm just like open about it
and i would like so why do you look at
it
i have a i came up with everybody just
for the record like
my ex-boyfriend who was gay i keep up
with him like i keep up with anthony
michael hall my first boyfriend i keep
up with every i know he's engaged
like he knows this too like i'll see my
first boyfriend when i was 18
engaged i'm like oh he just got a green
porsche oh he's in gay like i'm weirdly
like obsessed with people in my life
and what do you what's that oh you get
angry huh you get upset no that's more
him being like
oh you're looking at the vlog squad like
at the beginning now how does that make
you feel that she's
spying on on them no i think at the
beginning i didn't understand
how you know she was so connected to the
vlog swatch was part of their life every
day for years
right now i realized you know how big
that was to lose that so are you praying
for
like you praying for something bad where
you can celebrate
no no no but i like to see the decline
because this was like a standpoint
and now they're like [ __ ] them for the
pandemic like they're oh they're angry
at them
yeah so now i like to see because i
don't really keep up with everything but
now i can through them and they'll be
like [ __ ] them traveling to big bear and
doing 20 people in the house like yeah
[ __ ] them so they're very like honest
and it is a place of like again i like
to watch like the demise the stan pages
turn to hate pages
way too fast shout out to the tumblr
page keeping up with the vlogs
oh my god it's going to be bad it's
going to turn into a full-on hey
they talked all about big nick on your
podcast they did the recap
like because tumblr you write in an app
what did they think about it um
yeah they're like yeah that makes sense
like they're they're they're very
anyways anyways whatever
okay there's no bad people we're all
we're all
so far a billion percent yeah
everybody's here twitter twitter yeah
twitter just because
twitter justice
i follow like a lot of political
accounts and it just gets me so angry
oh i could see that yeah it's like ah
just don't want that [ __ ] in my head
trisha can i ask you something yes so
something about what you just said
there's i'm not going to sell them out
but somebody on our crew has a theory
maybe no say it because we're going to
talk about it yeah he said it on h3 live
oh did he say it yeah baby is the david
stan
no no no no this has nothing to do with
david okay oh oh never mind back track
step back not everything's about david
tricia not everything is about david
no somebody somebody on our crew oh has
a theory
that you religiously follow our
subreddit to find out about what's going
on oh hand to god i have no idea what
reddit or subreddit is like moses oh i
believe
no i do i do moses will look at it
sometimes and show me and i'm like i
have no idea what this is
there's a lot of fan art oh moses showed
me like the um
she tweeted the the ursula thing but i'd
swear i don't see anything i'm so
confused by all that i believe you
hand to god you know yeah i [ __ ] just
said that i love you she never goes
it's just it's been a theory internally
is it a b because he's an idiot because
he also is david's dancing
okay okay okay wait wait i'm in place
i'm not telling anybody else
because i was going to do a whole tick
tock about it but that's fine you
weren't going to go in on it
i was i was like you know david i hate
when people from the girl give them away
we'll talk about
like big nick me like i heard a
different story big nick you weren't in
my [ __ ] relationship you dumb look
he's friends with jason he has a fear
you're not in my relationship
yeah that all happened on camera all
right all right let's play this
hospital yeah
okay all right next question uh this one
is probably gonna be kind of easy but
[ __ ] it um so
i guess it's for everybody um who is the
best cook in the relationship
easy yeah all right go ahead and reveal
me uh trisha said neither neither
okay so oh you guys got it wrong oh
but that's not fair because we didn't
have time yet for her to
experience myself he's never cooked one
time moses says he's good for you i put
i i don't think i've ever seen him cook
ever yeah okay so what what have you
cooked moses you better start cooking
i'm a good cook to justify that how is
she supposed to know that
how is my sister gonna see me cook babe
nobody cooks it up
what the hell all right that's one point
ethan and yellow let's go
i just stormed off after this episode
you're going straight to the kitchen
it's always yours you are you wanna
you wanna say anything about that ethan
is a chef
and that's all i have to say thank you i
love you
i love you ten years i've never seen you
click anything like on tick tock or
instagram stories
well i don't i don't post yeah wait i
just can't family i just i it's not a
big deal i just cook you'll just ask me
like what do you feel like and i'll be
like
i don't know alfredo sauce with uh
peas and he's just like okay and he just
figures it out like he doesn't even look
up a recipe i don't know how oh my god
that's actually very especially alfredo
sauce that's so hard
it's he makes like a quiche without even
looking up a recipe
i don't know how you do that yeah well
thank you wow okay
i know what ela likes and i kind of like
have a few things
that i can you deserve that point babe
you never cooked once i don't know but
the thing is
but the thing is very pretty we don't
have time for that
look ila is very particular so i have to
cook for otherwise she wouldn't eat
if we if it was up to me we'd be eating
pizza every night so
don't worry about it all right
so this one uh this one might
might fray some relationships here or
whatever so uh
so should we order dominoes actually
yeah yeah what do you want on your pipe
this is a pizza party look at us we're
having we need to be eating pizza right
now
he looks like that should be the
question what is the other person
rock solid this game won't break you me
and moses are a little more rocky
who's gonna break you i hope your
relationship's stronger than that maybe
you guys shouldn't be getting married
no we're not going to get divorced
because of a poor showing of the
newlywed game
okay i'll make this i'll make this
question for
moses and ela towards ethan nutrition so
moses
and ela what is your spouse's worst
habit oh i think i oh
oh god that's so many so you two are
answering for yourselves what's up
what's our worst habit
wait wait wait who is it you're waiting
for me
what is ethan's worst habit and ethan's
gonna try and you should guess what
you're gonna say yeah
all right so we'll start with you two so
you go
go ahead and reveal staying up late
staying up late slash sleeping in
oh you can't change your life i'm not
changing okay
let's literally he's looking down both
of you guys oh yeah you should put yours
up no it's my decorations okay
okay eating pizza i guess that chill is
where our minds are
and moses has a habit like i don't eat
it's not like a habit
moses put yeah what to say what does it
say
picking wounds picking at wounds
i don't eat pizza that much although you
must really hate my guts when i eat
pizza
how could you say that instead of eating
up yeah
i think i overeated you didn't think
about it right you know oh there you go
overeating she did
eating well you said pizza
it's a bad habit all right we all got
what did you write oh yeah we're all
everybody got that one okay okay
disaster
elim moses what is your spouse's
favorite thing about themselves
oh my god this is actually really hard
this doesn't smell like getting into my
memory i don't like
it's so hard to like compliment yourself
but i'll just say yeah
i'll just write the obvious one either
huge [ __ ]
what was your favorite thing about
ourselves correct what's your favorite
thing about yourself we're gonna get
this wrong
okay okay so we'll start with you two so
go ahead and reveal your answers
oh wait who's showing no what else said
show your answer your answer i said
funny because i thought that was like
you say money
no funny i spend money i'm talking about
you said money yeah
we are all over the place this is a
disaster
wait stop stop stop since when do i care
about my hair i literally wear a beanie
i don't care about my hair at all
that's so ridiculous and then moses i
don't think i'm funny
i'm just trying to write something
that's obvious
hair and then you wrote you're rich
that's your best
money i was talking about all the years
i love spending
but what if you go broke sometimes i
still spend i was always flying first
class even when i was making like no
money wow
just on credit
you oh and you got first class tickets
oh wow yeah good for you thanks
awesome um
uh and moses let's not forget said
talented which
a little bit okay moses yeah i'm
definitely not yeah
i know all the time it's not that i
don't think you're talented but it's
like
that's like very broad uh general
wouldn't be rich if she wasn't talented
oh things
like i mean it's more specific i mean
funny although the hair was the best
look i just thought you would get it
hair i don't give a [ __ ] about my hair
it grows faster no but i thought like i
thought like if you had to pick
something
about yourself okay maybe you'd pick
that i don't know
i should have got nice hair
all right i don't like this game that is
hard it's a little hard these questions
okay
so this is for everybody what would be
your dream vacation destination
together
all right everybody ready all right so
ethan and trisha
we've got it maldives or
italy all right maldi okay thank you all
right so ela
got it wait why do you guys want to go
to maldives
um that's the bougiest place you can
visit notes
we're staying at an underwater hotel
that's thirty thousand dollars a night
for our honeymoon
okay it's like super poor country
the hotels there are so bougie thirty
thousand dollars a night to stay
underwater no i
okay i didn't know i think you're
thinking about uh all different places
yeah that's a difference oh i'm thinking
of something else maldives is like the
booziest like
that's the kind of a different place so
what did moses say moses your answer
maldives yeah
we all got it right so if ethan and
trisha could eat one food for the rest
of their life what would it be
ass oh i can't
wait okay hold on sorry i got really
excited because i'm hungry
you know what ela was subliminally when
she said my worst trait is eating pizza
don't get hints don't give me
i'm not i'm just saying like because i
was like let's get domino's that was her
being like oh you [ __ ] get done
i didn't think about that my worst habit
is eating honestly
it'd be nice i just thought i thought it
made sense
it tells me a lot about what's in your
psyche all right all right so ethan and
trisha let's see it obviously pizza
and then and then what did moses get
buttered noodles butter noodle pie
that's so interesting that
under your under your complex
personality
all you want you just want buttered
noodles even at fancy restaurants i
always get butter noodles
like the beverly hills hotel i'm like
plain noodles and butter
do you find noodles great so good
do you find that there's a different
range of butter noodle like if you go to
a fine
restaurant yes oh really i would my
dream on this podcast my dream guest
above anyone else adam sandler gerard
way brad pitt
is babbling with babish cooking with
babish have you you know him on youtube
he makes this amazing butter noodle
pasta it looks amazing he uses gourmet
butter
he puts a gourmet cheese puts a little
bit of pasta water back in the in the
noodles it's so good that
he doesn't break the noodles they're
homemade they're amazing i feel like i
can make you a good butter noodle
yeah yours always smell really good when
you make them for theater i go home and
make them for myself i'm like
that sounds really good i could try to
cook it for you huh maybe next
i mentioned it last time when we did the
cooking challenge to like see who makes
the best butter noodles that was my way
of like throwing it in there because i'd
be pretty good i'll prep it for you next
week
you use barilla pasta the blue box
whatever you got i mean whatever you
want
okay i do love butter noodles what was
yours pizza yes pizza
does anything pizza pizza i'll eat it
have been specific we said butter
noodles bro i don't even give a [ __ ]
what's on it i like penne i like chicken
parm but we said water noodles
okay well you what do i need to specify
the toppings i mean come on it's pizza
it's specific just cheese pizza
pizza
it's not specific enough jesus
i'll eat it with anything i don't i'm
not even kidding like i'll eat anything
let's favorite food
is that a question are we getting
another person could be if you really
want and now i don't have the meme
all right i mean i do i am curious i
want to know i'm not saying that
it's her mom's cooking oh moses are the
same thing there you go
you're so excited his mom i know
she's it's just it's a different it's a
whole it's just a different
world the cooking her mom's cooking
really because like
she cooks for like 12 hours it's like a
whole thing she wakes up at like five
and you eat it like five or well earlier
than that but she
three but yeah she'll cook the whole day
sometimes she'll prepare even the day
before
i think what's what's unique about your
mom's cooking is that you can't
really get it anywhere yeah you can't
just go out and be like oh i want
i want some of that why haven't you
learned to cook it for ela then like her
favorite meals from her mom
so here's my theory i've tried it's
really time-consuming i don't think he
has the time to like spend a whole day
cooking well
i've tried some of the dishes yeah and
we
hype we hypothesize that her mom
intentionally gives me the wrong recipes
because yeah even when i put in the time
and do it exactly like she says it never
turns out the same
so we think that she's giving it me like
just ten percent wrong
so it's never as good they don't want to
be fine
they will never be replaced that's why
yeah i don't think she'll ever give me
the truth
yeah every time you ask her she's like
oh it's super simple you just do this
and you put a little bit
like this and that put it in a bag with
honey and then flip it
and then flip it back and then put it
out and put it in the oven i was like
getting dizzy honey chicken sounds great
is that what it is
she makes this one with potatoes and
sweet potatoes with honey and a bag is a
little crazy bruh
we just want food on this episode we're
like where can we get them so ela are
you gonna
divorce me if we get domino's dumb and
hoes
i'm used to it no thank you
so let's get it no divorce order okay
yeah how do we get it why don't we
because i'd love to have a peace with
you guys we're all here i mean let's
have a pizza party
yeah the last time we got domino's you
we had the biggest fight ever that was
pizza hut oh my god but people
wait are you pizza or domino i'm
domino's oh so why do we get pizza hut
because they have the triple treat box
oh by the way oh okay because
that pizza was wasn't like not the
greatest okay
yeah because i was like yeah i don't
understand what's all the hype we love
dominoes
i get it all the time i love it let's
get you wanna are you okay
yeah well am i okay to get it you wanna
order it now or yeah yeah pause
we just ordered pizza and i'm so excited
thank you i love you so much
i love you more than ever thank you
thank you domino's for sponsoring
no i wish papa john's is out
i just need any pizza place to pay us
dominoes we'll eat every episode
yeah i'll [ __ ] i'll just turn this
into a domino's box
like a big domino's box with a number
i'm telling you domino's pizza get this
to them [ __ ] britney spears get this to
domino's marketing
do you know what some fun fact really
real quick is like because jack in the
box mcdonald's they do sponsorships with
influencers
but they don't do it with plus size
influencers because they don't want the
demographic to look at fat people and be
like that's what we're going to do yeah
they only want like skinny
it's like yeah maybe i got a mcdonald's
one or jack-in-the-box something and he
only eats vegetables and he
self-admittedly only eats vegetables and
like
how that's kind of funny they don't want
the actual fatties
they don't want to show the actual
people who are eating their [ __ ] just
have ela and moses eat it
for our sponsors yeah you guys want you
guys can eat it
[Laughter]
uh no we can i think we look good we
look pretty good for our size i mean
we're not like the 600 pound sisters you
know not yet
yeah no that would look bad if they're
like sponsored by dominoes
yeah they can't get out of their bed we
still bathe ourselves
no no hate though i can wipe my own i
like them i love that like tammy is i
don't even know i'm not saying i hate
i'm just saying it would be distasteful
for domino's to sponsor them for example
i feel for people who are 600 pounds i i
can i can see how you get there
people watch how can you get there i can
see how you can get there i'm on my way
would you sponsor them if you were
dominoes
yeah absolutely that'd be that would
look a little odd
no but they know food they you know we
know can you imagine that would be so
scandalous all right let's get it
all right next question they're just
always eating dominoes it's like coming
i'd buy it all right this is for
everybody uh
who is the better driver
wow this is a divisive question
look okay okay all right
ethan and trisha first now with peace
and love i will say i think we're both
good drivers hila
and so this isn't like i know both
spouses say
or usually between two couples it's like
one is obviously about i think you're a
really good all right just show your
answer
me
[Laughter]
you think you're a better driver than me
i love your whole explanation
yes i do you're just kidding with peace
and love i yelled at moses for driving
so freaking slow on the way here i'm
like you drive so slow it had six
seconds left for us to make it we're
right there and he like slows down i'm
like you have six seconds
how this is a fast driver so
she will if i drive too fast she get car
sick
if i drive too slow she gets up on the
side street but she's
having a full cup of starbucks in her
hands
he doesn't break until he gets like
right to the people and for the freeway
i'm like they're breaking my mom does
that it freaks me out oh he does it too
i was in a bad car accident i was 16
that way and i'm just like break break
and he never does
gradual break mostly yeah gradual
she does exactly the same and then she's
like sorry sorry do you mean that a what
all right all right come on we got a
wedding
plan
i'm kind of surprised either picked
herself though interesting i could see
that being a better job i do think
you're a good driver though like i said
it's not like i think
i'm just you know i had to pick somebody
and it was me
we all got it wrong who's winning good
question
good question ian what's the score uh
the score
is five uh trisha moses
six e3 it's a close one it is very close
okay is very close next question
uh this will be for ethan and trisha if
you're if
your guy's house was on fire what would
your spouse
grab before leaving not counting
children or pets
what's
yes moses what you would grab okay i
think i know it
i think i know it okay so
everybody ready wait wait okay wait
i don't even know what i'm gonna take
take a moment
yeah it's harder to do this reverse
because moses is
with peace and love moses is very like
basic so there's like you know he wants
he's very simple
he's simple he doesn't need anything to
take he just let the house burn and take
himself you know what i mean like it's
very simple
he's gonna grab something though he has
a choice
destroy everything or save one thing
he's gonna save something he's gonna
grab something
he's like i gotta go okay so write
nothing i saved nothing
what a nihilist let it burn all right
let's see what you two have
ethan and trisha reveal laptop uh
water painting ela said sketchbooks
i mean i was thinking your art i mean
you know
i thought about laptop too but moses
said laptop what did you write
his painting is or photos of water i
said paintings i could see photographs
water
i mean it's did yeah no yesterday we all
got it wrong you all got it wrong
it's all on my laptop though fail
you're so proud of your photos of water
wow
he told me he invented the photography
that takes pictures of water he told me
that too do you think that's real
i he seems to have a proprietary
technique i've never seen it
yes i'm the only one anywhere else i
mean i don't think he invented the
concept of photographing water but i
i've never seen no no no i did
oh well well i mean i'm not a historian
what do i know
i'll take him at his word anyways i
think him as well i've never seen
photographs like the one he takes but i
don't
i don't that's a big claim to say you
invented yeah
it's a big invention too okay
are you um do you have a patent
truck tank london shark tank yeah do you
have a patented
it was it was on wired magazine i mean
i'm the only person doing this
are you patented um no because when you
patent
it's just a matter of putting the money
into it
someone's coming for the brand after
this
they can try i love you he never talks
about that stuff with me because i don't
know it doesn't make any sense i'm like
okay but i'm proud of you i am proud of
you
yeah i'm there i'm right there with you
no i am i think it's cool
no it's it's amazing at least he has a
passion some people don't i've always
been a pr
exactly yeah yeah i've always been
impressed by moses he always
he's always has like his apartment's
always like this crazy
workshop not our house
that's why we're gonna have like little
places everywhere okay whatever
yeah he's bringing in the plants yeah he
has his own basement the basement is his
all right this is a big one this is a
big one hopefully uh you guys remember
it's a nice basement so this is not the
basement this is for everybody
who said i love you first
who can remember that such a thing i
haven't known it's like trisha knew
right away
[Laughter]
dude it's no i don't i really i
genuinely don't i do
i know who said for in your relationship
who do you think said it first i can't
tell you because i'm going to help you
again
exactly we know more i watched it i
don't think we fell in love at a
holocaust museum i watched the whole
thing
don't tell them okay i'm not going to
all right
ethan and trisha me me ela said
ethan so she got it right and moses
trisha
everybody got it right i guess they're
emotionless you know what i'm saying
i think i'm just
i think you're both more expressive than
there you go the two of us here
yeah moses says he likes affection
because he never got it as a kid not
putting anyone under the bus but i'm
just saying you know what i mean
i feel it i believe that i mean what
about are you
affectionate or not affectionate she's
not oh
i mean comparatively two households went
different well because
i mean you know if you their dad was
pretty austere
yeah my dad was too but i crave
affection my dad
never hugs me or kissing me but um i
love affection
i mean i love it i love it and ethan is
really good at giving affection i just
don't think i'm good at giving it
naturally she's like okay you're not
like the cuddler you're not like let's
cuddle
but in our relationship i'm more
affectionate to you yeah moses is oh my
god like a sucker fish in the morning
i'm like
oh my god it's always on me i love it
because no one's giving me that much
affection but
he's definitely the one that's always on
top of me cuddling i love it
gross snacks questions
[Laughter]
let's direct this one towards moses and
hila so
ethan and trisha what are your spouse's
biggest fear
biggest one fear biggest fear what is
ela and moses's biggest fear
hmm on what level in life
i think i have an answer i have one too
wait you do
babe just think like in life
the big picture um
big picture i don't know what that means
but like
like it's just one like okay what can i
say i'm rocky
yeah i'm not saying all right so ethan
and trisha let's reveal what you came up
with
i wrote cancer oh and trisha said
nothing oh my god we are on a whole
different level you look like
cockroaches
cancer is way scarier than cockroaches
yeah well
yeah what'd you put and then moses
could be without you okay he turned his
camera stationed like a couple days ago
and he's like i'm literally scared of
nothing
that's why i thought like i have
absolutely no fears but since we got
together
to be alone is something oh
no but that we do talk about that a lot
we hated being alone i think we just
hated being alone so much and we both
were like we
just need to be with somebody i love to
be without you
seriously because i have no fears that's
the only thing i would think
of nothing like nothing he just goes and
like does whatever all right
anyways thanks babe you'll never be
alone cockroaches was a good answer
but i guess i thought because she has
like a phobia of cockroaches
but i was thinking like i don't know you
went deeper i went i went further way
further
well it's it's also true yeah what
you're doing
it's just yeah but everybody's afraid of
cancer well and if you like experience
someone dying through it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i get it i mean i don't get it because i
can't imagine that would be awful so
anyways that's like
[ __ ] cancer [ __ ] cancer it's not a
campaign
it is can you imagine anyone that's
pro-cancer like they just want to be a
troll
i'm pro-cancer i think
i used to be pro cancer can i say this
for real like on my strange addiction i
said
they said what if you get cancer i'm
like whatever at least it'll be [ __ ]
hot i don't think that's probably
just not caring yeah i'm not broken
my mom had cancer so no can't no pro
cancer all right
all right that one was pretty dark let's
go a little more lighthearted uh
so ela and moses what is ethan and
trisha's
favorite flavor of ice cream
easy this should be easy
all right we'll start with ethan and
trisha go ahead and reveal
rocky road obviously
she said chocolate mint and
moses says rocky road oh the ice cream
100 percent
we never miss but you know i we eat i
eat it all the time like moses won't
have any
he'll have a coke for dessert rocky road
sucks i don't like nuts what is that
exactly i don't like the nuts in it it's
chocolate nuts and marshmallow
i love the chocolate and marshmallow
yeah but the nuts is like we don't like
this texture
you don't want it not too much ice cream
i love it
it's like getting chunks in two and
bubble gum it's like
no yeah no i love it
for dessert he'll have like one can of
coca-cola now you have a whole bunch of
rocky
you have a coke for dessert yep
interesting yeah it's a good
uh palette cleanser you've changed so
much
coca-cola you're the first person called
coca-cola
a palette
all right uh this will be for
ethan and trisha what is the best
present
that your spouse has ever given you
best present hmm
that you has ever got
hmm
i can tell you the worst tell me the
worst
hey my birthday last year we were
hooking up for months and like seeing
each other every day
and my birthday's our huge guy i make
birthdays huge deal for everyone him me
everybody
and he didn't give me anything on my
actual birthday but two weeks later
comes
i got your birthday present and it's a
framed picture of his
water photography that was a laugh
the first time he gave me his stickers i
was not amused i threw i left them in
the car so it's like i don't know why
you gave me i again proud of you so
proud of you and i love him now
if he gave me that now would love it
because i'm in love with you now but i
wasn't in love that i'm like why did you
get
in your defense that's what an artist
get also
i don't i didn't know you i didn't know
what you like at the time i'm a girl i
don't wanna
talk a photo of water
was it just an afterthought were you
like i need to give her something
no i seriously once i until i know
somebody i don't know what to give them
like i just didn't know it again don't
give your own that's why i said for you
a picture of me here's a picture of me
for your birthday
okay i need to actually think well
actually i am water it is the same
okay we have a time for the best gift
ela ever got me
i'm sorry i have no idea
is there a time limit there's no gift
giving is the love language in this
really he's writing
so we got something
i don't know i'm making it up just
random
what's your love language you're writing
like a paragraph there dude
yeah with peace and love
okay let's see it all right ethan and
trisha revealed
engagement right to mexico oh you want
some trip to mexico
i said with peace and love no breakfast
yeah well i gotta say ethan doesn't want
anything
yeah it's not your fault and moses he
got it right you know the diamond ring
was the winner i mean that's easy
i i i don't want people to think i don't
get him stuff i get him nice stuff he
doesn't care though
like gucci shoes he doesn't care oh oh
yeah but it's not for me it's for the
family it's like it's not like you could
hear yourself
she could have done it without you but
you could have done it without her
not him she needed my semen to make
theodore
would have been someone else you don't
know babies are made i know how babies
are made okay my semen goes inside of
her
that's the science
[Laughter]
all right all right what if our baby
looks like theodore because we i have
the same jeans as ela and i kind of look
like you you have the same genes as
either
yeah inside me when moses comes with me
i will have elo's jeans inside me too
[Laughter]
i think you're a lot i know but what i'm
saying is well yes
they'll probably look alike i mean they
have this yeah yeah that's possible
we'll be cousins
i'm excited for that oh my god and
trisha
yeah it's just so weird it's the
weirdest plot twist of any show ever
no
and maybe a baby crazy um
is it tied in uh yeah it's tied
okay be serious now let's focus all
right you gotta give me a crazy-ass gift
so that if we ever play this game we
know both know the answer
what do you want you gotta like stuff
ethan yeah rolls-royce
okay okay
all right no i would that would be so
weird if she bought me that you don't
even go anywhere
i'd be like if you either bought me
that'd be like what
that's okay though because honestly i
just sit in mine and eat pizza literally
i just sit in my car in the driveway
i think if kovid was over and we were
like driving every day the office i'd be
more
inclined to get a new car but it's like
it feels so stupid because i literally
never drive
yeah catch him got you girl next all
right next
uh where is the strangest place
that you guys have made love
that's a that's a straight newlywed
whoopee they would say well yeah
it is one of their questions they would
always ask on that show
thinking back to where we used to be
adventurous and not parents
strangest places i mean we've been in
quarantine so it's not really fair
thing is i don't know but there is one
does that include penetration or
just following yeah that's what i'm
wondering does it like
uh how i mean the question says make
love define make love
let's just either premiere and say me
and your sake let's just say
it doesn't have to be penetration okay
otherwise there's no like i don't think
yeah
okay let me think here
oh this is embarrassing there's two i'm
thinking outside there's two i'm
thinking of also
yeah well i think we already told it on
the podcast
no hints hey you giving it away no
thanks moses thanks for backing me up
i don't think we said anything about
this weird
well you got an answer
this is so embarrassing okay
you guys are you guys done okay all
right ethan and trisha first reveal
water museum oh i see
oh nightfall nightclub in tel aviv
right i should have known and then moses
also said water museum water museum
[Applause]
we haven't been anywhere the only place
that was not her house or my house was
the museum
and he's never had sex on that side of
his place before that's not that crazy
you guys
with all the water things okay yourself
it doesn't happen this is
it just is the craziest place okay i'm
just saying you always need to step it
up
you guys what'd you guys have sex on
like the dance floor oh no it's in the
bathroom no and it's not fair because
they did talk about it in the podcast
they did talk about it in the podcast
just that we hooked up in the bathroom
wow
in your skinnier days oh yeah because i
could never anymore like get inside a
bathroom and try to like
put my legs up well it wasn't that it
wasn't a stall it was like
a private bathroom with the door closed
he had room but there was more room than
you would
you're currently imagining oh my god and
she
then i couldn't you couldn't like pick
me up can you imagine two big fatties in
a saw trying to get it on
i've never dated a bigger guy so i don't
know i think that's why though just like
nature says you need one skinny person
in the relationship to like
lift up yeah man at a certain point you
can't do
you just can't it's just like hugging up
giant
it's just there's nothing going to
happen do you want to show
mike and molly melissa mccarthy's show
and there was another big actor and they
were both big people dating
that's the premise of the show is that
there were two fat people dating did
they penetrate
i always thought about that though i was
like so yeah they never showed like love
scenes
if you do you have to like lift your fat
like everyone has to lift their fat
and then like it takes some really
maneuvering that's what i do
you don't your belly doesn't hang over
no no yeah mine doesn't get either
i'm kidding not yet god i mean listen
we're working on it lena's coming with
some pizzas
so we're still tied no we we got you
guys just
yeah the water museum that's so
ridiculous
it what how is it ridiculous it was
weird though it was really awkward too
i was like about to leave and then he's
like wait
but it's just not weird it's his house
you guys don't understand the water
museum is attached to his [ __ ]
house no it's inside it's his house with
the bed and it's not there's nobody
in there no but what if you do it in the
teddy fresh offices
and you've never been anywhere else
since you met that would be the place
look you guys make your own rules i'm
just saying y'all need to
quarantine yeah you guys need to get
weirder than that
i expect more from you well
in the back of my car we did my ass
that's like that's more interesting than
the water museum no because it was weird
it was all like dark and ghetto you
could hear like sirens and he's like
wait real quick before you go let's just
walk over the couch i was like i guess
okay
[Laughter]
all right well i'm wishing you guys more
interesting love making in the future
i've always said i'm vanilla i'm not
that crazy i like to just like
i lay on my back turn around get on top
like that's it i don't do anything nuts
boom boom boom yeah i just you know i'm
rarely on top now
like potions get out some rabbits with
20 o'clock moses did say to me the other
day he's like you don't get on top
anymore i'm like oh i'm fat i'm getting
like the 20 pounds
i mean yeah i mean i don't think if i if
i had to crawl on top of elo i could
ride her i mean i think i would kill her
no i held myself pretty good i bounced
pretty good but lately i've been getting
too much weight so i'm like sorry
ah dude with peace and love i've seen
you get winded making a tick tock
yeah this morning i don't think you're
supporting your weight very much no i
was actually i'm good at supporting my
weight i'm good at holding it
oh my god our bed almost broke a couple
times so i stopped doing it for real
i had to reinforce our bed but it was a
shitty bed because when he got on top
too it also cracked so
it was just a shitty bud all right back
okay okay all right all right you ready
for the next one yes
this one is kind of a joke one but we
had to put it in here oh
okay so for ethan and trisha
your spouse went out for oh i want to
tell that beach story because i wrote
beach
that was so creepy remember that yeah no
we weren't sick we were
we went to like a nude beach just for we
didn't know it was a nude
i went to a beach in santa cruz but it
was pretty much empty there was nobody
there
so we were just hanging out and we
started like making out and stuff naked
no no we weren't no you guys weren't and
then i looked behind me and there was
this
creepy old dude jerking off watching
though and me and ela got so freaked out
we immediately bounced
but i guess that's he probably just
thought like we were exhibition because
it was a nude beach we just we didn't
knows and it would be i don't know
that's beach though
it was so disgusting we thought it was
completely empty because there was no
one like visibly there
well we went to like a far corner too we
went away from everybody and then
i turned around there's some [ __ ]
naked dude jerking off like from 20 feet
behind us
we were immediately packed up and
bounced so that guy was like well they
don't like that
i like it some people might like it
actually like sure yeah
he might think you know it's a nude
beach but we were clearly
in like a private area was this when you
guys first met
it was yeah i mean she it was when she
no i don't remember
i never remember the second visit maybe
yeah oh okay so it's early on because i
don't think we ever just like
went to a beach and made out with each
other like i never have the urge to like
make out in public i think that's cool i
mean we were younger you guys are
we were younger yeah we're older we had
more we had more
uh what's the word horniness
yeah yeah i get you
hello yeah no i'm just thinking about it
all right go ahead dan yeah it was weird
though all right sounds like a good one
that's a better that's good story
that's why we're at the beach i'm going
to ask this question to
moses and ela your spouse
went out for pizza without you
what do you do what to get who's just
for ela
yep what do elon moses do if
if we went out for pizza without them
right this is a [ __ ] question yeah
yeah it's that's a meme question oh okay
i'm a new age after i don't know these
things it's not fair
but i'll put but i'm gonna show that the
answer regardless
no wrong answers yeah and that doesn't
count this can be a freebie go ahead and
show your answers ethan and trisha
p and the baby in the basement
did you say anything what did you say
these postmates
made their own food oh you're talking
about the food what did you write
you just keep working on my stuff i mean
it could be whatever really
sad your girl goes to pizza without you
what do you do
no but you don't understand she does
that every day when she does a mukbang
so ethan and trisha what is one thing of
that your spouse
would love to get rid of something that
you guys own
that your spouse would love to get rid
of
that's not it's a hateful question
hopefully we own
i don't know
i'll just write i'm gonna write i don't
think that this is real but i'm just
writing it because
it's the only thing i can think
i think it of make your life it would
make your life easier let's say that
if i can try to telepathically
communicate with you here
it would make her life easier
i don't know if i if i could
erase one thing out of my life it would
maybe help your life a little bit erase
something out of our life or something
we own
something we own one
thing that i could throw out that you'd
be like okay that's cool
oh all right you're running out of time
now or never
never oh i got it this isn't the dead
air show people we have a show to do
people like dead air oh really yeah why
would anyone want
us to sit here silently let's call me a
little bit of people call me
why don't they just go outside and
listen to that air outside why are they
watching this show for dinner i don't
know that's a good question
i got it i got it from you guys ready
okay ethan and trisha reveal
ps5 the ps5 yeah exactly not really
though
not really though yeah just like you're
on moses
oh he gets pissed if i'm like lighting
candles are you sensitive to
that yeah he's sensitive to smell yeah
it's about the smell and the smoke of it
in a closed room
i need fresh air you want to throw our
candles out
no it's more certain smells like now we
buy them together once that we both like
they're like why is
that close he came over and just blew
out my candles i'm like excited you did
that
and you opened the door i was like no
that's funny
because i love candy i must have really
irritated him though what i can't
breathe i don't know that i would have
the balls to blow out a girl's candles
though
i do it all the time everywhere even in
people's home if i go don't you ask
no i can't breathe it's like he's like
weird as [ __ ] when you first meet him
that's why i don't know who this
is now oh he was sober he's like
that's kind of a wild thing to do i used
to be like i only like you if you wax
not shave i'm like oh my god you can't
just say that to a girl first week of
meeting me i was like
i'm gonna shave like i don't know what
to tell you like
they say it that way though that's
pretty ballsy too i didn't say that way
though that's
what did you say how did you say it more
of his preference you know yeah you just
say just so you know
i have this problem not the first week
of me no you wax or shame now
it wasn't like that eye shape are you
okay with the shaving
but it wasn't like that she brought it
up and i was like yeah you brought it up
no i did not you're like
i just prefer a wax i'm like okay i
shake
moses says you asked him and he answered
the question
she brought it up she said something
about you know that's what big ed did
just saying
yeah oh when we watched it that's
exactly what i thought i was like you
cannot say that to a girl although
to be fair gave it as a gift i didn't
say that
it's already like really everyone feels
so sensitive about this topic already
like girls because it's like well i was
just saying she's
so there's a big there's like a [ __ ]
there's a huge chasm in what happened
here
this person i just met five days ago
should i wax or shave
no no it's not that crazy i remember it
exactly she brought it up she didn't ask
me she brought it up she just said it
and i said i prefer yeah i prefer wax
that's my house
whatever you wax your pubes moses no no
but i would never tell her what to do
that's for sure
he did at the beginning not anymore he's
very like whatever even if i don't shave
you better you're gonna be in a
long-term relationship you better get
ready for now
he's great now like honestly like is a
different person i'm like who is this
person like i don't even know who this
person is he's like
insanely nice like who are you and same
here
same here you know and he's like doesn't
matter if i wear a big ass underwear
he's like those are sexy i was like
he's just y'all better get used to it i
mean that's what it is oh no he doesn't
care at all if i don't shave for like
four days like whatever like he doesn't
care
i mean what are you doing for a month
she can do what she wants to do that's
not true he's such a liar he would turn
he would not be with me all right no but
we have the same preferences
hates bushes this isn't the pubenning
what is the problem you do with pubic
hair these days i knew i didn't room
just grow
but shave it all come i love shaving it
all completely but is there a new trend
like a landing strip you know that was
like popular 90s is there like a trend
now with pubic hair you're just shaving
it close
i just shave it all i don't know what's
the trend why not i'm not married
forever i like to shave for myself like
i go nuts but i'm just saying
yeah okay just groom
you ready yeah all right uh we'll direct
this one to moses and ela
if your partner could choose a
profession outside of entertainment
what would it be very interesting
so wait who's this for their you're
answering for yourself
what you would do if you wanted an
entertainment mine
what the f would mine be yeah same
i feel like we just talked about this
too what would my preference be
because they're all all the things are
creative i know
you have an answer elo i literally don't
know
well i kind of know what you wanted like
before
yeah i don't know if you still want okay
i think i know
oh i think we talked about this actually
it's funny because this answer is so
stupid like i would never do this
it's like i would never [ __ ] be able
to do this mine's like
real i think i would do this and i can't
even spell it that tells you how much
it's embarrassing that i can't spell
this i'm going to look it up and you
want to do a spelling bee
i would love to do one with you um dr
phil i think
that i think that i spell better than
ethan i know it is pretty funny
oh yeah because like you have a whole
different alphabet that you grew up with
you're a good sign i remember like
you're really you are you're very smart
you know i mean you're very smart
what can i say it blows my mind when
people from i don't feel like i'm smart
though i feel like you're smarter but
you're probably like
it's different all right ready i'm ready
i looked it up i'm not
all right ethan and trisha reveal what
you said
so ethan's a physicist and you said
why wouldn't i be able to write comedy
but that's still creative that's not
fair well they got it wrong anyways
you're right eli your answer is right
i'm wrong
you're right ila i'm wrong i would say
that's still entertaining dominic
i actually would genuinely love to try
and work at domino's you said domino's
work yeah that's a true one
what was moses's answer i applied very
ambitious
lawyer wait what was the question again
my dream what would i what would i want
to do if i wasn't in my current
profession
yours is right yeah you answer right i
said feminist
i said physicist i'm a [ __ ] idiot
you're right no your answer is right
it's comedy i don't even know what a
physicist is what does that even mean
you'd be a horrible converter you'd have
to stick to physicists you'd be a better
physicist
you think so i just don't think you're
like you're funny
but i don't think you could write for
other people okay funny write me a
script one day and i'll write you a
script see if there's a better shot
right oh you think you're good act one
act one
eating domino's pizza sitting at home
and big granny underwear eating pizza
i love that treasure you're not wrong
you're not wrong about that yeah
thank you that's your strength you're
funny
on the spot you're improvised yeah okay
that's what you do no it is
a compliment all right i'm a physicist
can't even spell it can you be it if you
can't spell it
no no no definitely not yeah
but you said domino's so i mean at least
your expectations are in the middle
of the day twice and they they said no
both times
they're like yo tone down your
expectations a little bit literally yeah
they never hired me
much lower than domino's worker rude
i'm just saying like if you're not
qualified to be a domino's worker i
don't know what the [ __ ] you can do i
guess a stripper because i got hired as
a stripper yeah stripper at a ghetto
strip club go godfathers and van eyes it
was a really ghetto
the godfather prostitutes are there for
sure
so wait what so we both got that wrong
right what did you write moses
lawyer i was thinking about movies
you're talking about a lawyer
your honor i'm kind of arguing my case
i believe you're good at arguing but the
whole difference
wow i'd love to see you in a suit being
your honor
wow it's not happening with peace and
love your honor i think you're a [ __ ]
idiot
peace and love is your thing not mine
your honor i would like to open with
saying
i think you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
whatever you do no she would say like
your honor
you're right right you're right yeah no
she's like
right right i'm a good lawyer
i also thought we should try maybe
circus acts like being a trapeze artist
or something
oh yeah you'd be good at that you get
winded making a tick tock on the trip
you literally got winded it was a joke
no you wasn't a joke there was nothing
rolling
yeah ethan you do too oh
called out oh yeah guys but i'm saying
who's in better shape you know what me
no let's do an office support
get that lined up see who's involved
let's do that
[Applause]
you will not you can't even i don't even
think you could support like
and write it down in the uh i'll do the
future episode
pull ups i'm in oh please you cannot do
a pull up i can do a pull up i can do
bipolar
okay no i don't think i don't think you
can use anything in here but holy [ __ ]
there's no way you can
i was a stripper i pulled myself up on a
piece maybe you were a stripper 100
pounds ago
i just no listen it is rude but there's
no way you can do a pull-up now
strong i'm [ __ ] strong it takes a
little does anyone think she could do a
pull-up
yes thank you babe we'll have to see no
let's go use some speculation we're
going to find out what's on this book i
have to carry my weight around all day
i'm so [ __ ] strong i pull myself up
from [ __ ] okay i'm sorry
i'm sorry for saying that because i say
my point is that i think maybe you could
do a pull-up but
you would be let's just get on the
obstacle course you know what when conan
went to israel he actually trained
he did the obstacle course for the
israeli army i feel like we could do
that too like climbing over those walls
we could do that same course
oh my god i don't think he must be good
over the first lap of the call
actually moses did shade me and say you
couldn't do that i was like excuse me i
couldn't do that
no okay let's set up an obstacle
let's just do a fit we could just go
down to a playground anywhere and be
like okay do one pull up and both of us
would be like
nobody should get off of course like
going over the tires and let's do it
like we don't need military grade we
need the fifth grade playground do it
like uh
like ninja warriors yeah ninja warrior
we're not even gonna get over the first
like thing kill it i've done physical
competition on reality trisha really
thinks she's a ninja warrior i am a
ninja warrior
oh my god get me on a date with no nails
i've got it just give me a
i love that i love that let's get out
and do that i'm so excited
presidential fitness test i aced all of
it except for the mile i did the toad
you're talking about you were like 12
years old yeah did you eat all of it
how you performed in high school has no
bearing on what's happening here right
now stronger now
we ordered a gym set i put 75 000 on gym
equipment i'm like working out
okay you bought gym equipment doesn't
mean you could do a pull-up i'm doing it
god i wish we had a pull-up bar here
i'll do it right now
there's no way you should do a single
pull-up i can do a pull-up
and we should give you guys we should
give you guys like a month
to train so you have like i don't know
now they're turning in some weight loss
[ __ ]
okay no
no it was like
no i could kill it i did taekwondo i did
kickboxing i did all this [ __ ] i was a
volleyball player
you can't do a single pull-up and i say
that with peace
like literally give me a stripper pole
i'll literally put myself upside down
right now i'll climb up that boat i just
say stripper bowl i said
pull up i can do it i think you were
never able to do one so you're
projecting that on me dude i uh
listen what i was able to do at 18 has
no bearing on what i can do now
and i could do it like i'm stronger and
i could do it like i'm stronger now
i used to be i used to do one arm
pull-ups can we go to the next okay well
can you do that now
no of course
and that's not a good thing my muscles
are bigger okay
just cause you have little baby arms
doesn't mean that you can't
you'll pull up better than me i can do
one better
listen i'm not sure either of us could
do it but if anyone's doing a pull-up
it's me
i got it i'm so excited for this oh my
god we got next week we're going to the
[ __ ] playground
i think we need to go to the like the
literal playground
because i don't i don't think we deserve
any more respect than that
like i don't even think we can make it
across the monkey bars
oh easy i'm a monkey bar champ i don't
think you can go
where did you get monkey bars oh i did
monkey bars like
i don't know don't say like live i don't
want to like lie but
okay we're going to the playground
continue
your rest is grass you're asking i'm so
excited let's celebrate by eating some
dominoes
that'll help i should be here shortly oh
yeah where is that domino's all right
all right uh next question um
so for ethan and trisha what is your
partner's
weirdest quirk oh
there are so many yeah
[Laughter]
ela's very normal i've always thought
she's like a very normal grounded person
really
yeah oh that's so interesting how
different they are
i guess the age difference maybe yeah
he's got the brunt of it as like the
he's the youngest so he got the most
well he's the oldest they're all
the oldest yeah moses got the most
[ __ ] up yeah and his
his mom was like young and yeah my
sister got like the youngest generally
i think it's just when the parents
aren't ready because like when my sister
was born my parents were really young
she got like most [ __ ] up peace and
love of course
oh you guys are the baby both of you i'm
the baby and so is he oh god
we got the best oh no no that's the
worst
no i think that too babied maybe but
like my parents were
most financially stable and they were
like most mature when they had me
well babies the family are bad because
they get everything handed to him
because my sister's the baby i'm doing
everything hannah okay my sister my
sister loves the show i love her
okay she's great she's doing her own
thing now what are you middle and the
middle challenge yeah you're [ __ ] up
like yourself middle child problem
middle child
isn't there's issues with the middle
class well that's definitely true i've
got the most mental
health issues for sure okay i'm the only
one who doesn't use anything
no i didn't write anything ela what's
the weirdest quirk where does quirk
um okay i'm gonna write something
this is the one that i think bothers me
the most
okay how do you describe a cork like um
just like something unique weird unique
thing that you do
this is something that annoys me about
you
that was not the question just a cute
quirk that's not a cute quirk you're
like this
is the question what was what's your
weirdest quirk is the question
the weirdest weirdest it doesn't have to
be like people
it's more about being strange or unique
yeah
i think this annoys me about you i'm
something [ __ ] but i wrote something i
wrote something
did you ever get annoyed with each other
or no not that much moses never gets
annoyed with me
ever i was like what's wrong with you
like i just sat there for the saturday
for the second move
i literally sat on the couch while he
like put boxes up and down the stairs i
was like aren't you like annoying me
that i just sat here all day for eight
hours while you did all the work he's
like i'm annoyed
i'm annoyed i didn't help i'm annoyed
too i was like i don't want to stay here
for eight hours like
this is boring how's that not annoying
you moses
i don't know sitting down seems to me
seem more boring she doesn't help you
she does help in different ways
different ways
i think moses just knows what to expect
no but that's the thing there's
different balances we we balance each
other well but he wasn't even pissed
he's like you want to get some food i'm
like you're not annoyed i'm just sitting
here doing nothing about being on my
that's what i want to do
but i know that you will kill me so i
help no but the thing is she's not lazy
she's a hard worker if she was a lazy
person
right right a different story right
that's true you're not lazy
you're the breadwinner kind of well
ethan is not lazy but i would still kill
him
yeah yeah no no i would be my head i
would be dead if i
if because like if we move he was like
she's on it she's like oh really
she's like packing unpacking she's like
so focused and working
and i'm like i'm just if i sit on the
couch i'm [ __ ] toast
did you oh really what do you do you
unpack two i don't know i just take [ __ ]
out of the boxes and try to figure
something out no he
was something that something that ethan
will do is like
get all the utilities or sword or
insurances
and all that stuff which i hated so yeah
i don't do that either
they're all under money's name yeah well
now our business manager handles all
that thank god i don't have to think
about it
oh yeah we need to get like a helper i
think most of it's just too much
like at this at a certain point managing
all the bills and the insurance
and stuff it's like i'm starting to miss
stuff and like car insurance and then
it's like it's just it's so [ __ ] up
it just becomes a lot to juggle my life
is so complicated
[Laughter]
all right you guys have an answer yeah
yeah all right so ethan and
trisha i gotta write bigger you can
water cloud water slash
cloud obsession what does that say so i
wrote picky eater
cookie eater picky i was gonna write
that but that's not a cork
is it i think it's a core yeah it's kind
of like
what'd you write i was gonna write that
she literally wrote that guy no
no she was gonna write picky eater i
don't know
and moses said i am water he has a weird
ups like a really actual
he's not kidding and i tell him you guys
got that right you know what i say to
him i'm like i think you're trolling
with this and he's like no
he literally thinks when you die you
become the water absorbs your body and
that's what you become
i'm more sometimes i worry about moses
because he's got this
he's so obsessed with water yeah but
with peace and love
well he gets his i think we think he
might be a little autistic and with
peace and love
something's uncomfortable on his neck
like he gets he like i mean he might
have
something but yeah i think it's awesome
he'll just stand there and be like the
clouds
like out of nowhere you might be like
adhd
no no anything around his neck smells he
gets like crazy he's like oh i can't
like
hyper sensitivity yeah he's
hypersensitive that's part of autism
i love it i don't okay welcome all right
i just never thought he knows that he
knows he is no i
i know i've i've heard people that are
on the spectrum describe it and then i
realized oh my god that's exactly what i
mean
interesting i love it i love that we
both have a little bit of a
um something wrong with us well we all
do yeah
yeah so cool with peace and love and i
think that's a good thing because i can
speak out now for autism people like
oh my god now you're championing autism
you don't even know if he has autism
we think he does okay so now you're
going out for
oh our waiter told us tourette's tick
tock is a big thing right now i forgot
to tell you
i'm not i'm not participating in that
it's people trying to finish a sentence
and they can't do it that's not that i
don't have that issue
but just maybe something with your hand
just put it on tik tok
okay i'll think about it try and maybe
write something and see if you can write
a word down without doing
that come on i'm not like a [ __ ] like
pair police
you know ethan ethan always does that
when he plays video games
and then his character will like look
around really
that's the problem when he's streaming
is because when he plays with people
they're like why is he doing that what's
wrong with him
i'm hard and i tell him sometimes i tell
him just say it that you have it and it
doesn't want to
because it's like a conversation it's
like yeah i need to accept can you put
that on tick tock because always
every time i go i have two yeah you
don't have tourette's what are you
really doing and i say no i have
tourette's and they go what does that
mean what is it it's like
it's not it's just turns into this whole
conversation put it on tick tock tick
tock is a big thing
and that's a real thing to rest tick
tock
yeah my way our waiter loved it he's
like i love threads tick tock i was like
oh what is that
i'm not like a i i don't know it just
yeah he was telling us about it
i don't know you gotta you know at least
if you have to live with something bad
at least you know
make money off it yeah so i mean
you know yeah it is annoying playing
video games because i'm always like
looking in the top corner of the game
it's like an ocd thing and it
it just it makes it actually harder to
play the game because i'm trying to like
play a boss and i'm keep looking
i'm playing on like extra hard mode so
you have ocd and tourette's
yeah tourette's is like related to ocd
and overeating
anything else though i think i have
three things too i think i'm
bbd schizophrenia and overweight you're
not schizophrenic
i have early onset no yeah you're 35
you're
32. you're 32. you're
maybe that's the pizza maybe that's all
right all right
i didn't hear anything the pizza so i
feel like uh
so how many questions wasn't fair what
no you lost you had the right answer
yeah you you didn't write it
i should have just wrote it i don't know
i love that you know like i could have
put this
it's fine i'll take the l i think you
guys are winning what is it yeah yeah
what's the score
it's 11 trisha moses 10 eatanila
we had more than that oh calm down moses
you guys you're winning let's keep going
let's cover some ground before the pizza
gets here okay okay
the pizza is here that means the show is
over
so what we're gonna do is um we'll do
you guys are up by one point we're going
to play one more question for two points
okay so either you're going to slam dunk
us or we're going to win by one
we're going to slam dunk it all right
it's got to be a good one let's see um
oh i feel like this might be good okay
ethan and trisha who is better at
haggling prices oh
wow i know
what that's like so easy
okay i mean i
i know what you wrote
[ __ ] okay is a wild man are these
middle eastern
i mean i think that's part of it yeah
israelis are [ __ ] up that was the
whole thing on conan was him haggling
prices in israel did you see that did
you ever see him go to israel
i think i saw him yeah and he literally
was like how do i haggle prices i'm like
is that a thing people do over there
yeah they do oh okay
i go over there especially at the market
and [ __ ]
oh i don't hear anyone are you ready
okay are you ready
let me write this bigger i feel like i'm
writing so small you can't see it on
camera here let me write
so you can read it okay ready all right
reveal what this is he and moses
i feel like aren't i always negotiating
with like brands and [ __ ] in the email
like i'm always like haggling that's
true
that's not really haggling that's
negotiating is there a difference
between haggling and negotiating a
polite way of saying it
haggling is like for a dollar
negotiating's for like ten thousand i
pay triple
this guy was gonna sell us a purse for
200 i'd always give him 300.
i swear we did that on thursday i
all right you guys win that's it you
guys crushed it so
i'm not i'll just say right now i'm not
donating to joe austin
[Laughter]
let's just go eat some pizza okay that
was fun though that was a good wholesome
experience
yes that was that was fun cool and we're
gonna go successfully pizza together
without
having a meltdown it's the first time
pizza
because last time we never got to eat
pizza goes so now and if you guys want
to watch us eat pizza you better go
follow us on tick tock fish 88
ethancline h3
dude that one clip of me going like are
you go
going like it's so bad
i saw it on my page on my home page they
had like nine million views and then i
just
made a video of me watching it and i was
like this guy i am yes
yeah because the guy they like reenacted
it perfectly and i was like the guy's
better than me
and it got like so funny i mean they
actually had more than that didn't you
did they take us
oh he tagged me i think i don't think he
got the tag this has nine
my reaction is nine million views that's
so crazy
all i did was watch ever wait i thought
you said you liked my tick tock
uh wait you don't like my ticket the
poop thing was weird they have 11
million views
did they take us on it no they didn't
tag us they didn't even say frenemies oh
apparently everybody just knows
but there was people reacting to them
and how popular we are
uh yeah we're killing it but there was
people reacting to them
saying this guy's hilarious not even
knowing
that it was about us i was like what
it's crazy how dare they i mean i was
splattered that
but people who knew knew in the comments
i saw the comments that they knew they
knew
they know they know real ones only who's
the real hmm
[Music]
dude i am i felt so bad for that
documentary i feel so bad for her
yeah i feel i honestly free britney
free brittany i'm gonna join brittany i
want to go into the house with her
make trisha brittany's name conservative
conservator
i won't argue with you jamie i just want
to love her too okay thanks for watching
everybody have a great week and we'll
see you
and if you want to watch more podcasts
of us without trisha i mean who would
want to watch that
no no no i can't do that
no don't forget everything we don't do
anything
else next tuesday monday another friday
tuesday everything else in between
is filler
[Music]
you